ich hoffe es ist okay für murat dass ich
jetzt eine neue große liebe habe
und dass er kevin heißt
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so soll
israels ich bin so glücklich denn in
meiner küche scheint die sonne es gibt
nämlich endlich einen neuen teil der
mini und der neue minions film kommt in
die kinos und zwar ganz genau am 30 juni
bzw seit dem 30 juni läuft der film
schon in den kinos und ich bin richtig
glücklich denn ich darf wieder eine
motiv dort oder verpacken aber ich denke
wir sollten uns erst mal den trailer
anschauen damit wir erst mal alle wissen
worum es geht auf jeden fall spielt das
ganze in den 70ern deswegen münchen
verkleidet und es ist praktisch die
vorgeschichte zu allen minions filmen
die wir bisher kennen
bekommen bei den füßen 6
ihre seite besteht der werke der
bewerbungen gehen
bin ich auf was war endlich war
sie gegen die ständigen nicht gegeben
ich habe das gefühl ich spürte
tombola abstatt diese laut stadt nicht
erfordert wird
glaubst du ernsthaft dass ein mickriger
kleiner junge einfach ein schurke werden
kann wir haben weil ich einfach
unverbesserlich wie kommen die
etwas besseren gemacht hast beeindrucken
mich
den stein ins rollen stoff - der kleine
kinos geschlossen
[Musik]
selbitz versteckte sie ab
das ist der wichtigste teil des labels
dieser junge hat gerade etwas von exoten
templeton
schon jetzt
du musst mich gerade auf die norm habe
ich recht
wo ist der starke
kontrast
[Musik]
komplette zukunft
[Applaus]
[Musik]
oh ich wollte euch nicht erschrecken ist
wo
das ist otto den kennt ihr jetzt bereits
aus dem trailer und otto ist eine neue
figur bei den minions und ich hab mir
jetzt überlegt dass ich otto als 3d
torte zu bereiten werde ich möchte
natürlich dass otto so steht wie auf
diesem foto und am besten drückt ihr
euch zu hause wenn ihr das auch nicht
frei hat machen wollte am besten drückt
ihr euch einfach eine schablone aus in
der größe wie es sein soll hier ist
wichtig überschätzt das ganze nicht also
meist gerne das bild einfach mal aus bei
mir hat otto jetzt eine gesamtbreite von
etwa 20 cm so an der grössten stelle
2022 und das passt auf jeden fall denn
die torte wieder dreidimensional die
wird hoch und dann wird es echten riesen
brocken an otto und an minions torte und
weil er die minions bananen so sein
leben möchte ich natürlich eine panne
antworte machen gut schmecken muss es
gut aussehen soll ist und ich muss mir
jetzt hier erstmal alles abzeichne alles
ein überlegt mir dann noch ein konstrukt
wie ich die torte zum stehen bekommen
denn so einfach es ist gar nicht nur 3d
torte zu machen die dann aufrecht stehen
soll ihr könnt natürlich wenn ihr zu
hause eine million leute machen wollt
könnt ihr natürlich eine torte machen
die einfach sitzt also praktisch einfach
nur sitzen davor ganz einfach aber ich
stelle ich mich ja immer so ein bisschen
selber deswegen messe ich jetzt hier
alles aus wie für dich mit deiner rezept
dann konstrukt
einfach nur schritt für schritt
entscheiden
[Musik]
nachdem ich jetzt hier die gesamte höhe
und breite und die einzelnen elemente
wie augen und beine aus gemessen habe
überlege ich mir jetzt ein konstrukt
damit mein minion auf seinen zwei
kleinen füßen stehen kann benötige ich
da nämlich eine holzkonstruktion und
damit der geschmack von torten am
wichtigsten ist kommt jetzt erst mal der
innere aufbau von otto für die 3d torte
backe ich verschiedene bananen
stracciatella böden bestreicht sie dann
mit aprikosenmarmelade damit so ein
bisschen fruchtig schmeckt und füllen
sie dann mit einer bananen buttercreme
und damit der medien auch wirklich auf
seinen zwei füßen stehen kann setze ich
ihn mit zwei holz stehen auf eine
stabile holzplatte stapele dort dann die
bananen böden mit marmelade und butter
creme im wechsel und festige die torte
zusätzlich mit einem cache bord als
zwischenboden aber das zeige ich euch
später alles noch im detail anschließend
wird die torte da noch zurecht
geschnitten mit fondant eingekleidet
dann noch dekoriert und sollte am ende
dann so aussehen
ok jetzt habe ich theoretisch einen plan
mal gucken ob der sich in die praxis
umsetzen lässt ich fühle mich kurzum der
dem kleidchen kann ich jetzt nicht so
gut packen ich glaub ich stelle mich so
ein bisschen wie die minions und dann
legen wir einfach los mit dem planung
für kuchen cannabis entscheiden
[Musik]
der kuchen verwöhnen wir ich bereit 100
gramm butter
300 krw was man erlebt sagt beck die
dürfen gerne immer warm sein von 100
gramm bananen etwas zitronensaft während
das computernetz 150 kamel da nimmt er
am besten kann ist von eva mendes mit
plus 1 15 backpulver und 100
doch die frauen ein afp-reporter red die
mag ich besonders gerne
ich hoffe es ist okay für murat dass ich
jetzt eine neue große liebe habe
und dass er kevin heißt
kevin und ich packen jetzt den bananen
kochen ich kenn ich würde sagen du setzt
dich jetzt mal nach hinten und darfst zu
gucken und ich backe jetzt okay
[Musik]
für den rücken gibt die jetzt am besten
die weiche butter eine große
rührschüssel dann salz und zucker mit
dazu und vanille extrakt minions auch
ganz gerne aber
wenn
das so frech das schon so viel
angestellt hier vanille extrakt noch
dazu und dann die zutaten erstmal schön
cremig verrühren
währenddessen bereite ich jetzt auch
schon mal meine back ringe vor ich nehme
jetzt zwei park ringe und stellen sie
auf 20 zentimeter durchmesser 1 und 2
back ringe auf 18 cm durchmesser und
weil der teig etwas flüssiger werden
wird könnt ihr die torten ringe jetzt
einfach in etwas backpapier einschlagen
und dann passen auch 2000 bringe jeweils
auf ein backblech man kann man schön
parallel backen dann gebt ihr jetzt
nacheinander die zimmer war mayer mit
zur butter masse und jedes ei wird
ungefähr für eine minute eingerührt
damit die masse schön homogen wird in
der zwischenzeit könnt ihr auch gerne
die bananen schälen mit zitronensaft
beträufeln und schon mal ein bisschen
zerstampfen
doch doch die banane brauche ich doch
für den vornamen kuchen
okay wenn auch mit zitrone damit nämlich
die banane nicht braun wird
hier nimmt die banane nimmt ihr einfach
können dir da kommt da stehen
sie mit den kindern oder okay ich habe
es schon weg ich habe ihnen kommt setzt
sich wieder
und dann kommen jetzt die pürierten
bananen die buttermilch und abwechselnd
dann die mehl backpulver mischung und
die streusel noch mit in den teig und
jetzt wirklich nur noch ganz kurz führen
bis sich alles gut verbunden hat
und dann könnt ihr den teig jetzt in die
top-riege einfüllen und dann im ofen
backen
[Musik]
die böden sind gebacken und ihr könnt
natürlich auch während des backens schon
anfangen ihre details zu modellieren bei
mir ist so ich habe alle würden gebacken
nacheinander ich habe auch tatsächlich
die doppelte menge gemacht also einfach
nochmal vier böden damit ich einfach
genug höhe habt für dominion und jetzt
wird aus blüten passte alles modelliert
was eben fest werden muss und es könnte
ja auch gerne ein paar tage vorher
machen
aber dort
also blüten passte entweder eins zu eins
mit fondant verkneten dann habt ihr
nämlich modelliermasse oder wenn ihr
sagt dass nun wirklich alles schnell
fest und trocken werden dann auch gerne
blüten passte einfach nur ganz alleine
verwenden das funktioniert dann auch
ganz gut
und ich nehme jetzt hier einfach wieder
meine vorlage die originalgröße und habe
hier noch eine kleinere vorlage wo ich
einfach die ganzen größen aus gemessen
habe und hin geschrieben habe und anhand
dieser vorlage werde ich jetzt einfach
alles modulieren das heißt ihr könnt ich
auch ganz gerne an ihrem laptop oder am
handy so ein paar bilder von den minions
öffnen und schauen wie sie eben aussehen
und ich werde jetzt erstmal anfangen mit
der brille dafür habe ich jetzt die
blüten paar tische und weich geknetet
und mit becker stärker könnte sie immer
ausrollen und etwas kokosfett falls ihr
so ein bisschen fett braucht zum
beispiel jetzt nämlich in den
ausbaustopp da habe ich jetzt hier schon
einen 5 mm abstand drauf und kann das
ganze schön ausrollen
da wird mir nicht gleichmäßig
damit die brille der minis richtig schön
dreidimensional wird setze ich sie jetzt
aus drei elementen zusammen zuerst
steche ich zwei kreise aus die eben
genau so groß sind wie meine schablone
das sind die zwei einzelnen kreise als
nächstes brauche ich dann noch ein
zusammenhängendes stück was eben an der
front ist sozusagen die vorderseite der
brille damit man da nicht zusammenkleben
muss hier könnt ihr auch die aussteller
einfach so ein bisschen als schablone
nehmen aber eben nicht komplett durch
drücken sondern später mit einem
scharfen cuttermesser einfach drum rum
schneiden
da wird die brille dann am
dreidimensionalen gewinnt kommt jetzt
hier noch ein zwischenstück rein dafür
rollt ihr die blüten passte ganz dünn
ausschneidet gleichmäßige bender zurecht
und setzt sie dann zwischen die zwei
elemente
damit die brille ist auch nicht gerade
wird sondern schon mal eine schöne
biegung hat könnt ihr den tortenring
nehmen den tortenring ein bisschen
einfetten und die brille auf dem
tortenring dann zusammensetzen
alle teile die ich miteinander verkleben
verklebe ich mit essbarem kleber
[Musik]
hätten sie nur sondern lesebrille wie
ich gern das wäre einfacher
[Musik]
wenn ihr kleinere kreise oder pünktchen
ausstechen wollt dann könnt ihr immer
ganz gerne kleine thülen benutzen mit
einer loch thüle davor und nehmt dann am
besten so ein bisschen an getrocknete
blüten passte weil es dann einfacher
geht und sie sich nicht mehr verformen
und
wichtig ist bei solchen motiv torten
immer dass ihr detailliert arbeitet hier
mehr details und so kohler wird die
torte
kooperation brille beendet die lassen
wir jetzt schön trocknen und kümmern uns
um die anderen die tales
für die brillen scharniere habe ich
jetzt hier auch ein bisschen blüten
passte kann sie ordentlich
zusammenrollen laut anleitungen und
schablone zurechtschneiden und dann noch
kleine details rein markieren
[Musik]
trägt ja eine zahnspange deswegen freue
mich jetzt hier kleine kügelchen die
alle möglichst gleich groß sind kann sie
dann mit einem holzstück einfach ein
bisschen zusammenrücken einmal in die
einrichtung und dann in die andere
richtung
wie heiß die denn die zahnspangen teile
ich hatte eine zahnspange wie heißen die
weiß dass ihr beweist es von euch jemand
ich könnte gern einfach mal in die
kommentare schreiben zahnspangen
[Musik]
aufkleber teil
mit rad
jetzt bekommt mein kleiner autor hier
noch seine zähne dafür braucht ihr ein
bisschen größere kugeln drückt sie auch
flach und schiebt sie dann auch mit dem
holzelementen so ein bisschen zusammen
dass sie zwar rechteckig werden aber
trotzdem noch eine schöne rundungen
haben
und alle teile die ihr hier formt und
modelliert könnt ihr immer wieder auf
eure schablone liegen so könnt ihr
nämlich sicherstellen dass alles
proportional gleich ist
damit ottos jeanshose natürlich auch
noch ein paar details erhält bekommt ihr
hier noch die kleinen druckknöpfe dafür
nimmt er auch eine etwas größere loch
thüle könnte mit etwas essbarem kleber
noch kleinere kreise draufkleben und
dann habt ihr alle teile die jetzt
trocknen müssen fertig
druckknöpfe erledigt
die haare sind jetzt dran
otto hat zehn habe
[Musik]
nehme ich meine blüten passte und etwas
schwarze verpasste damit ich die blüten
passte färben kann
und dann werden die haare geformt
wenn es klebt einfach bisschen becker
sterkel nehmen
[Musik]
kann man das denn meine instagram
biografie schreiben minions friseur
million hair stylist
[Musik]
tus haren ich dass ich ihm ein oder zwei
jahre zu wenig gemacht habe
246 18 10 haare für otto apropos 10
kennt ihr eigentlich schon die zehn
fakten über die medien hier kommen sie
die zehn fakten über die minions die
minions haben nur fünf verschiedene
frisuren glatze mittelscheitel ecke
lockeres haar die minions haben nur drei
finger drei
minions können auch im weltall überleben
denn sie brauchen keinen sauerstoff und
können extreme kälte ab die sprache der
medien es ist eine mischung aus englisch
französisch spanisch und italienisch mit
russischen und koreanischen elementen
die minions wurden schon zweimal für den
oscar nominiert einmal für den besten
animationsfilm und einmal für den besten
filmsong
fast jeder weiß die lieblings frucht der
medien sims bananen was keiner weiß am
zweitliebsten mögen sie äpfel und
papayas
knapper bayer
thomas gottschalk spricht dem neuen
minions die stimme des wilder knöchel
knacker ein ehemaliges mitglied der
fiesen 6 bei den minions gibt's nur die
zahlen eins bis drei h steht für 10
423 und demnach 0044
minions kommt aus dem englischen und
bedeutet soviel wie royale diener
eine lieblingsbeschäftigung der minions
ist das singen und tanzen
[Musik]
ja
was macht dir
belaste weiter button kein quatsch mehr
hier in der küche
dann kann sich hier mit den details
weitergehen aber es immer gut so zu
wissen zehn fakten über die minions was
man eben so als mini und fan wissen muss
ok dann habe ich jetzt hier schwarze
modelliermasse die besteht aus schwarzem
fondant und blüten passte beides habe
ich jetzt verknetet und damit auch
wirklich ganz schwarz ist weil blüten
passt ist er weiß habe ich da jetzt auch
noch mal verpasst damit rein gegebenen
schwarz jetzt sind die füsse dran ich
muss immer mich an meiner originalgröße
halten damit ich eben auch die details
originalgetreu proportional zu bereiten
kann das heißt die füße die sind schon
wirklich ziemlich klein
und da brauche ich jetzt einfach mal
zwei gleichgroße von dort stücke
untreusee zu einer kugel und verweise
dann leicht oval
fast schon hinten so ein bisschen flach
drücken
vorne so ein knubbel lassen und dann
kommt da gleich noch eine sohle dran
[Musik]
dann sind jetzt die hände dran und wie
wir wissen haben die medien handel
34 und die basis ist diese schwarze
kugel für die handschuhe könnt ihr jetzt
hier einen ball tool verwenden und oben
eine kleine öffnung reinmachen dann hier
nur noch zweimal einschneiden so dass
drei finger entstehen und alles mit den
fingern so ein bisschen aus formen
die hände die linsen
und aus schwarz und weiß werde jetzt
gleich grau und daraus wurde legt dem
stein was es mit otto und dem stein auf
sich hat erfahrt ihr natürlich im film
[Musik]
den stein einfach nur und formen dann
leicht oval und mit der hand flach
drücken damit das handeln musste so ein
bisschen sich auf dem stein abbildet
dann sieht ein bisschen echter aus
perfekt dann habe ich jetzt alte teils
vorbereitet und kann ich endlich füllen
der torte kümmern und weil ich jetzt
wirklich schon sehr sehr viel zeit muss
ich sagen aufgebracht habe für die
vorbereitung der ganzen täter könnte
jetzt gerne entweder ein echter
nachzubereiten das ist eine schöne creme
schokoladige creme die auch schön
festwirt rezept findet ihr in meinem
blog bzw oder ihr macht zum beispiel
eine swissmedic buttercreme oder eine
italienische kathrin denn die ganze
torte wir dann später mit fondant
eingekleidet und der untergrund also die
creme muss einfach von dann tauglich
sein ihr könnt aber auch ein bisschen
einfacher machen und ich will jetzt auch
ein bisschen geschmack mit reinbringen
deswegen geht es bei mir keine bananen
betroffen ich zeige mich jetzt wichtig
hersteller
da muss erst mal trocken
[Musik]
für die butter themen verwende ich zwei
päckchen butter kleben zum anrühren das
sind 500 gramm 500 gramm bananensaft und
600 gramm weiche butter
die buttercreme ist halt jetzt für diese
torte wirklich perfekt ihr verrührt
jetzt das buttercreme pulver einfach mit
dem bananensaft und las dann etwa eine
halbe stunde quellen dann wird es so ein
bisschen kleister artig aber das gehört
zu und nach etwa 25 minuten werde ich
schon mal anfangen die butter so ein
bisschen weiß schaue mich zu hören ein
trainer mit großen brüsten
während die bananen nach sitz noch quält
kann ich jetzt mal die elemente für die
holzkonstruktion vorbereiten dafür
schneide ich jetzt noch meine rundholz
so recht habe ich hier meine rund
ausgeschnittenen holzplatten und die
zeige ich euch jetzt eben mal hier habt
ihr jetzt also die übersicht was ihr
jetzt quasi zum stapeln und füllung der
torte braucht die große dicke holzplatte
die etwas dünnere holzplatte zwei
kickboards mit unterschiedlichen größen
zwei lange rundhölzer vier mittellange
rundhölzer und 2 bzw drei kurze rundholz
satzung stabilisieren der füße das
brauche ich jetzt alles für die
konstruktion und jetzt wird gebohrt
bevor ich aber ich hier jetzt die löcher
rein bau werde ich erst mal ein ersatz
holzstück nehmen und da einfach den
bohrer testen ob die bohrer stärke eben
auch zu dem durchmesser gepasst und eben
auch zum thema
wenn ihr euch hier beim kreuz markieren
auf dem kreis debug matte zu hilfe nimmt
könnt ihr euch ja wirklich hier dieses
kreuz einfach nehmen dann ist es
einfacher dann braucht ihr nicht mal
meinen lineal
1,5 cm rechts
15 cm nach links und dann ist der beiden
mittelpunkt jeweils drei zentimeter
auseinander
und bei den kickbox ist es ein bisschen
einfacher da könnt euch wirklich auch
die matte zu hilfe nehmen und auch den
mittelpunkt markieren dann die
kickboards und die dicke platten
übereinander legen
mit dem klebeband bisschen fixieren
und damit nichts verrutscht erstmal
einen nagel durch hämmern und dann kann
ich jetzt hier das loch durchbohren den
nagel entfernen einen dübel reinstecken
und dann hier das zweite loch bohren
und die zwei dickeren löcher die brauche
ich ja quasi für diesen stab und die
brauche ich nur in der deckenplatte
dann sehen wir jetzt gleich ob ich alles
richtig gemacht habe aber ich habe jetzt
die zwei dicken löcher nicht ganz durch
geburt bis zum boden weil es hat jetzt
so auch schon genug stand ihr müsst dann
nur bedenken so weit wie die zwei
rausgucken so hoch werden die beine lang
werden die beiden natürlich
die kommt hier rein
ja
dann die zweite kies
[Musik]
zuerst dran machen sondern
und die erste tortenplatte also das
erste cache bord ist kleine seit ich
fast aus wir sehen hier noch das dicke
loch durch geburt gut dass ich es nicht
gemacht habe
und dann kommt da boden füllung boden
füllung
dann kommen die hier rein sagt sagt sagt
sack dann kommt das da rein damit die
torte die zweite ebene einfach auch mehr
halt hat dann kommt das brauch ich muss
das jetzt schon vorher wissen bevor ich
hätte darauf starb dann ist es leer und
damit die stäbe nicht durch rutschen
werden die jetzt auf mit zweite platte
clapton
und dann brauche ich den medien hier auf
falls ihr ein bisschen mehr stabilität
wollt könnt ihr hier einfach noch ein
drittes bein sozusagen mit reinen dübeln
dann hält die platte hier wirklich
extrem groß dann gebe ich jetzt platte
am theater
und da geht es mit der buttercreme
vielleicht weiter
[Musik]
für mehr stabilität könnt ihr dann
einfach auch diese erste platte auf die
stelzen aufkleben und das geht am
schnellsten mit der heißklebepistole
die holzkonstruktion ist vorbereitet
jetzt geht es weiter mit der buttercreme
die bananen maße ist nämlich jetzt schon
schön dick wollen jetzt kann ich also
die butter schön weiß cremig verrühren
den banalen kleister dazugeben und dann
ist die banane buttercreme fertig
am ende habt ihr dann eine richtig
schöne luftige fluffige buttercreme
natürlich ein bisschen viel ab oder
myvideo de klein ich will mir sitzen nur
mal um
damit ich einfach ein bisschen besser
arbeiten kann nämlich nicht alles auf
einmal dann habe ich hier meine 8 bilden
sie waren jetzt auch im kühlschrank
schon natürlich schon eingepackt damit
nichts riecht damit sie nicht
austrocknen so sind sie schön kalt und
zum stapeln bestens geeignet am besten
packt er sie auch einfach einen tag
vorher es geht am besten dann habe ich
jetzt hier noch etwas aprikosenmarmelade
die könnt ihr gerne auf dem herd
erwärmen damit sie flüssiger wird gern
mit etwas wasser oder zum beispiel mit
bisschen schuss als aprikosen likör
ziehen und dann habt ihr hier eine
schöne flüssige masse die eben gleich so
ein bisschen frucht mit ins spiel bringt
ok dann in einen teller eine torten
drehteller dann eine universal hatte
dass es nicht rutscht wunsch mein
gestellt jetzt wird die torte gefüllt
wir starten erst mit den kleinen böden
die werden dann mit aprikosenmarmelade
bestrichen buttercreme drauf und der
nächste boden drauf da nämlich jetzt den
ersten boden der wird hier direkt
aufgespießt ich muss das noch ein
bisschen schief gebohrt haben deswegen
ist das hier leider
macht nix aber ich muss doch ein
bisschen gerade biegen
denn die platte später kommt er noch
drauf
geholt dann kommt marmelade drauf
buttercreme und der nächste boden ich
mir nehmen jetzt erstmal zwei kleider
böden dann die vier großen und bietet
die zwei kleidung ganz einfach
[Musik]
jetzt genau an der stelle dübel nicht
vergessen denn ihr seht ihr jetzt hier
an der stelle fängt ja der skateboard an
hier ist mein dübel hier die torte auf
und genau hier muss jetzt praktisch das
zweite kickboard drauf dann gleich die
torte weiter dübel wasser stapeln
ansonsten wird sie nämlich in sich
zusammenfallen weil es einfach zu hoch
wird das heißt jetzt nicht vergessen wer
ist denn andrücken und die dübel die
vier die ich habe diese elf zentimeter
langen hier rein geben einfach an vier
punkten wie beim hausbau boden stellte
boden
[Musik]
so wie jetzt kann ich hier drücken und
die torte fällt nicht zusammen und hier
jetzt einfach weiter stapeln und dass
die zwei hier nicht länger sind das ist
völlig okay
[Musik]
als letzte boden
drücken kriegt mehr stabilität
jetzt können sie noch im weinfass werden
aber es wird otto
das ist dort raum
und das wird gleich zugeschnitten aber
zuerst muss sie dort jetzt in die
kühlung damit die buttercreme festwirt
und das liebe ich an buttercreme denn
das passiert wirklich relativ schnell
ich guck mal ich hab die im kühlschrank
räume hier kurz alles auf und ich glaube
ich bestreite dann noch und stellt sie
dann über nacht abgedeckt kühl war ich
dann einfach so das größte hinter mir
habe und die torte dann einfach schon
fest werden kann ja also jetzt erst mal
einen kühlschrank stellen hier noch am
rand die reste weg
rund um schreiber den gleichen
wie so ein dönerspieß
und jetzt macht der griff nach dem gerät
wird nie müde tech gerät schlecht meint
er gerät schneidet das fleisch war
[Musik]
jetzt gefällt mir die form richtig gut
beim stapeln könnt ihr es euch einfach
machen und auch beim backen ihr packt
einfach 218 böden weniger das heißt ihr
macht die einfache menge und noch mal
die halbe menge denn wir brauchen
insgesamt nur vier böden mit 20
zentimeter durchmesser und zwei mit 18
und dann habt ihr nämlich diese schöne
form denn otto ist ja nicht wie kevin
lang sondern eher so zusammengedrückt
und dann habt ihr unten in 18 4 20er und
oben den 18 dann passt perfekt und jetzt
könnt ihr hier am rand die creme schön
glatt ziehen am besten nimmt ihr seine
torten rand folie damit geht es nämlich
echt gut ihr braucht doch nur so ein
kurzes stück und könnt dann quasi von
unten nach oben die creme an den
rundungen so hochziehen
erstmal die rundungen und dann den rand
am rande des perfekt wenn ihr datei
karte nimmt die hat hier einfach nur
schöne gerade fläche hier seit diese
skateboard und da könnt ihr sohn
wirklich auch schön dran setzen
[Musik]
form passt größe passt dann kommt es
jetzt abgedeckt in den kühlschrank bis
morgen damit die torte schön durch
kühlen kann und sie eben schön stabil
ist für die fondant decke morgen werde
ich sie allerdings noch ich hatte so ein
bisschen so ein hauch rest creme die
wirklich aufbewahren die kann ich jetzt
in den kühlschrank stellen aber ihr
könnt sie auch gern bei raumtemperatur
eine nacht auf gewarnt das ist auch okay
einfach nur mal kurz durch rühren und
morgen einmal glatt streichen aus der
restlichen creme die hier schon voller
kuchen krümmels und hier die restlichen
kuchen böden die kann man jetzt einfach
so als klarste
heute erledigt
da jetzt endlich wieder eine in meiner
küche bin und meine ruhe habe beim
backen kannte zwei tatorte weitergehen
weil otto eine zahnspange trägt so wie
hier muss ich jetzt natürlich erst mal
die mundöffnung machen und ich hab hier
einfach meine originalgröße ich habe
aber die zähne raus geschnitten damit
ich weiß wo das ist ihr könnt quasi das
bild immer schön als schablone verwenden
jetzt guck ich kurz und wo die forderung
wo die rückseite ist aber das passt hier
ganz gut hier ist meine vorderseite und
dann lege ich das bild einmal hier an
unternehme ich hier module werkzeug und
kann das hier schön an zeichnen und
aushöhlen
dann hier etwas creme rein streichen
damit die brösel wieder überdeckt sind
[Musik]
dann gebe ich da jetzt einfach etwas
schwarzem fondant rein als untergrund
sie nehme ich jetzt die einzelnen szene
passt sie von der größe heran und kann
sie dann in den mund kleben
der richtigen zahnarzt ihre damals zahn
für zahn angepasst werden damit
ordnungsgemäß stimmt
jetzt kann ich kurz kontrolliert fast
fast
perfekt alle teile die jetzt silber
gehören könnt ihr entweder mit silberner
pulver farbe oder mit sahne metallic
spray besprüht
[Musik]
köln
dann wird sitzt gelb ich habe jetzt hier
einige päckchen von land und die werden
jetzt schön weich geknetet damit mein
auto eine schöne hülle bekommen
[Musik]
da habe ich jetzt hier den weichen von
land und der wird auf becker stärke
schön ausgerollt ich denke die menge das
müsste es schon hin ich probiere jetzt
wirklich eigentlich überlegt den
partiell abzudecken also erst oben unten
dann die seite aber ich glaube ich hoffe
dass auch auf einmal ohne naht jetzt
[Musik]
gucke ich es einfach ich nehme die
fondant decke setzte sie über medien und
werde von oben nach unten nun quasi die
decke schön glatt streichen und nach
unten hin nämlich die reste weg und
tricks fest und dann ist auch wesentlich
schön oder so
ihr könnt auch von vorne nach hinten
oder wie gesagt partiell dass sie quasi
oben was macht dann hier einen breiten
streifen und von unten her weil diese
übergänge die werden ja dann überdeckt
durch die brille zum beispiel oder auch
die hose aber wir probieren
ich habe jetzt einfach so ein rohr mit
dem lässt sich das wirklich gut glätten
am rand das für meinen spritzbeutel
einfach übrig
ok dann schneiden will den mund aus
schön vorsichtig
am besten
wo ist er denn darüber
dahinter hat er belog arias wofür leider
weg machen
aber gott sei dank weiß ich wie eine
professionelle zahnreinigung geht
erwartete und so
perfekt otto bereit für die zahnspange
auch die kriegst du erst später wenn du
vielleicht schon augen hast
ja
gehört die zähne sind wunderschön
geworden und der für die torte mal schön
eingekleidet jetzt kommen quasi die
latzhose und dafür habe ich jetzt hier
blauen fondant ich halbierten jetzt aber
erst mal vor all den gleichmäßig
durchaus auf 3 mm und dann kommt da mit
jeans struktur ein das zeige ich es
gleich noch
wenn ihr jetzt ein bisschen struktur in
eurem jeans haben wollt nehmt ihr euch
jetzt am besten eine präge folie könnt
sie auf den von hand legen und entweder
leicht andrücken oder mit einem
ausbaustopp drüber rollen
und erstmal den unteren bereich vorne
hier überdecken und damit alles
originalgetreu ist einfach hier an der
schablone einschneiden dann könnte
nämlich schön die höhe abschätzen dass
hier dran legen und euch markieren
und dann mit s-bahn klebe angriffen erst
vorne und dann noch mal hinten und an
der seite machen unschönen art
[Musik]
wird das dann habt könnt ihr alle jeans
teile mit so einem präge rad einfach
schön einprägen damit das ganze eben
auch gut aussieht
wenn armenien jetzt schon mal einen
jeans untergrund hat dann könnt ihr euch
immer wieder die schablone nehmen sie
zerschneiden und die ganzen einzelteile
der jeans ausschneiden mit einem pre
gerat einprägen und auf den linien
aufkleben so dass er gleich eine schöne
latzhose an hat
dann messe ich jetzt noch hier die wie
heißt denn das
träger die labs träge glatzenträger die
mäßig noch kurz aus denn es muss er
jetzt an der torte auch von vorne bis
hinten passen also von hier dann geht es
hier so quer über
die länge
markiere ich mir das jetzt will ich
muss es ab
30 sender wir da für die abstürze gerne
mit dem bisschen geld könnt ihr auch
hier die breite ausmessen und wirklich
gleichmäßige streifen schneiden und
[Musik]
zum prägen lege ich das hier einfach
zwischen die abstandshalter und dann
kann ich ja auch schön gerade arbeiten
[Musik]
die beine
für die beine nehmt ihr euch jetzt etwas
blaue modelliermasse also mit cnc pulver
umrandet damit die holz beine so dass
man die eben nicht mehr sieht und setzt
dann die schwarzen schuhe noch dran
also an action liebe werde ich minions
chirurgie
oder minions modedesignerin
drück mich anfragen anfragen einfach per
dna kurzen moment natürlich muss ich
kurz die instagram biografie anpassen
[Musik]
beim fondant orten arbeiten ist immer
ganz wichtig dass man den überblick
behält das heißt für mich aber auch dass
ich über blick auf dem arbeitsplatz hat
deswegen habe ich hier meinen torten
arbeitsplatz hier kann ich ausrollen und
nebendran habe ich einfach mein werkzeug
und da beim werkzeug mache ich es immer
so ein rondell mit sauberem werkzeug
tablett mit schmutzigem werkzeug und
dann hat man halt am ende das große
chaos
jetzt habe ich hier meine fondant masse
mit cnc pulver und kann einfach die arme
ganz schön dünn und schlaksig formen
[Musik]
hier oben ein bisschen flach drücken
damit ich es angegeben kann und dann
kommt an die toten
[Musik]
dann sind jetzt die augen dran
unternehme ich jetzt aber jeweils eine
kugel weiß drückst leicht flach damit
sie noch so ein bisschen plastisch
bleiben also nicht ganz flach eben
sondern dass der augapfel so bislang
nach vorne guckt und dann platzt ich sie
an die richtige stelle
und dann kommt noch mit braunem fondant
einfach die pupille drauflegt ihres
braucht mit schwarzem fondant die
pupille
[Musik]
tokio
hey
autos brille wird dann doch mit einem
schwarzen band aus fondant befestigt da
schneidet ihr einfach ein schönes band
gleichmäßig zu könnte es dann noch gerne
mit dem präge werkzeug einprägen und
dann an der torte anbringen da
hoffe ich dass du sitzt hier so bleibt
so gut
und liebe
[Musik]
ich lass nach vorne bisserl überschuss
zwecks brille das muss dann nämlich noch
drüber
mein gott oh mein gott kann mit einer
schere geben
immer perfekt
[Musik]
das ist immer besser
jetzt kommt der schwierige part die
brille
weil ich könnte meine ausmerzen aber ich
habe eine gemacht und die brille die ist
nicht schwer ich habe es ja zum glück
leicht hergestellt aber damit die
trotzdem nicht runterfällt werde ich
jetzt daran stocker beziehungsweise
schaschlikspieß einschließen und muss
einmal durch die brille durch ich
probiert es jetzt einfach mit meiner
modelle werkzeug bunsenbrenner heiß
machen doch rein born und dann kann ich
sehr gut drauf setzen
[Musik]
die 2
probieren was ja
gesungen
der beton
[Musik]
alle knöpfe
otto
hahn spange
schade dass ich kann zwar als kittel hab
mir guckt da unten immer schön an den
zahn helfen sie ist das
wo einmal
[Musik]
jetzt noch mal ganz weit auf genau
einfach locker lassen
ganz kurz mit diesem werkzeug unter die
lippe
können kurz wissen ziehen und drücken
ja er super machst du das auto super
klasse
schon vorbei
ganz genau da brauchst du keine angst
haben und deswegen liebe kinder richtig
zähne putzen aber bei der richtigen
zahnarzt in seiner auch gut aufgehoben
korter keine angst habe
[Musik]
perfekt
geschafft
bevor jetzt autos haare dran kommen
praktisch der letzte schritt mache ich
jetzt jeden rand noch schön weil es hier
so ein offener treff liegend geweckt
weil es hier so ein offener rand ist und
holz rand und den wenig nicht so toll
wir haben jetzt hier einfach einen
regenbogen ausgedruckt stehen schneide
ich kurz außen clip dran
[Musik]
mal
otto bekommt jetzt noch haare
hat stoppt bevor du die haare dran macht
muss ich ihnen das polieren ok
danke bis jetzt gut kanzler machen danke
super wenn man leute im team hat die
mitdenken
so läuft
bitte zählt noch mal wie viele haare hat
otto marl auf dem sich zehn aber guckt
mal bitte und digital noch mal auf
youtube und ihr daheim ihr könnt mir in
die kommentare schreiben wie viele haare
otto hat
[Musik]
motto dein stein
hier ist doch wirklich
fertig ist otto der neue linien
ich bin so glücklich und ich bin richtig
stolz auf die torte muss sie echt sagen
dies so schön geworden ich glaube dass
die erste torte
bei der es mir echt leid ozean zu
schneiden
otto ist eine wahre kunst figur geworden
und ich habe direkt in mein herz
geschlossen
aber ich hab dich zum fressen gern
[Musik]
jetzt gibt es bei euch hier ein richtig
großes gewinnspiel das alles ist zu
gewinnen +4 kinotickets das heißt wir
verlosen vier tickets für den neuen film
minions die suche nach dem mythos ihr
bekommt dem camp in dem ich schon
richtig ins herz geschlossen habe und
eigentlich nicht weggeben aber ihr
bekommt kevin von uns und ihr bekommt
hier ein schönes back paket von mir mit
zum beispiel silikon back matte den
ausfall starb mein koch und backbuch
pinsel medi spritzbeutel sit back mail
und hier noch ein paar lebensmittel wie
[ __ ] is back transkranielle extrakte
tonga und wenn ihr beim gewinnspiel
mitmachen wollt dann schreiben wir doch
gerne in die kommentare
welcher ist denn euer lieblings medien
charakter ich bin schon richtig spannend
also meiner erst foto natürlich hatte
ich mag ich auch kevin okay wenn ich
drauf
ich wollte ihn schon war schon kurz
geben aber david chapman stiftung
ok jetzt wird gleich otto angeschnitten
die mädels dürfen gleich probieren was
die mädels noch nicht wissen sie werden
überrascht wir gehen nämlich gemeinsam
auf die minions film premiere und
deswegen werde ich ihnen gleich sagen
wir schauen uns im film im kino an und
sie freuen sich darauf aber sie wissen
nicht dass sie dem kinofilm in münchen
anschauen werden und jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt samira in
die durch die torte probieren
[Musik]
wie viele tiere otto
ja das ist der ort oder die hose nicht
richtig hoch gezogen wie der papa
manchmal
ja ich kann mein papas pedrosa aber gut
autos hupen ist zumindest richtig süßes
so ist bei williams nur ok wollt ihr die
torte probieren ja
zu schneiden und wollen wir vielleicht
auch mal ins kino gehen und den film
anschauen
kennt ihr auch das aktuelle lied dazu
wir tanzen gleich noch dazu würde ich
sagen okay dann schnapp dir mal deinen
teller auch hier zeigen wir in echten
beschneiden alles tut mir so leid ist
glaube ich echt die erste torte bei der
es mir einfach leid tut dass ich sie an
schneide auto
und hier doch nochmal den fotos sehen
ja darum eine zahnspange ist deswegen
mädels schön immer zähneputzen schön auf
die zähne achten ja
ja das erfahrt ihr im kino wenn wir ins
kino gehen
ja
da hat mag die augen
hat das erfahrt ihr im video
das party im film ich bin cool
okay gut jemand ganz bei mir war dass
ich kurz anschneiden
okay wir schneiden den anja otto
[Musik]
wonach könnte der mini schmecken ratet
mal
lasst uns probieren
immer zuerst
ich glaube wer mal in einen minion
reinbeißen würde
wird er genauso
schmeckt
und freudig auf den kinofilm sehr gut
ich freue mich auch schon richtig drauf
und ihr dürft euch natürlich auch freuen
denn zum einen könnt ihr beim
gewinnspiel ganz gerne mitmachen und zum
anderen dürften natürlich auch einfach
so in die kinos der film noch bereit
also ich würde sagen schaut ihn euch
angaben machen einfach immer gute laune
ich freue mich mega drauf und vor allem
freue ich mich auch schon auf den film
ihr wisst bescheid viel spaß beim
nachbacken wird zum nächsten mal ich
hatte so viel spaß in diesem video es
war ein harter hammer und ich würde
sagen wir tanzen wird noch ein bisschen
feiern mit den linien und dann geht es
richtig ab
[Musik]
ja
also das interview sequenz hat er heute
nicht geklappt haben spontan einen
aufruf gestartet werden möchte torte ist
und jetzt finden einige darunter essen
geboren und heute überrascht und ich
freue mich aber jetzt vom die torte
endlich auch weg und ich glaube die
zuschauer freuen sich hoffe ich
zumindest ich hoffe sie schmeckt
ja
[Musik]
dafür war der film für kinder aber auch
erwachsene und da kommen wir ganz schön
viel mitnehmen ich finde man lernt ganz
gut dass noch als aussenseiter ganz gut
teilhaben kann die ein land doch wieder
immer gekürzt
[Musik]
franken
man hat auch eine größere schüssel
nehmen können
setz dich
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der soll doch groß
und wir arbeiten so
und
und dann sehe ich von unter guckt ja
keinerlei
[Gelächter]
lockermacht stück kurznummer auftritte
kann schnell kurz ein frischkäse
herausgeber
[Gelächter]
erst wenn er
[Musik]